hello you viewers today we're doing that
fuck-boy playbook right side up subway
don't type of phone books what do you do
it that's legends a go from would not a
legend if you're aren't you our viewers
a [ __ ] up bro yeah well yeah a lot of
people don't know the definition of
public I want to explain it right
there's a difference which means a dick
and a football your dick will come up to
you approach you do all these things or
[ __ ] we will do the same the difference
is when it comes to getting into your
pants or [ __ ] we will be deceitful will
be this honest will be very fraudulent
about when you touch my dick he'll just
be an [ __ ] and you'll have sex and
just say I'm not interested that never
wasn't I told you that from the start
I so I'm going to go through with the
pigs I used to watch flat for when you
deal with a boy so say number one of the
haircut is that [ __ ] side cut with
the little garden on top little
community garden back cause I love you
is the next thing
Nazi Germany this is that haircut that's
what everyone decided to import they
kill millions of Jews after getting
those haircuts and I was in North
America the first casualty of all this
fun poisonous our hopes for Humanity
okay look at this look Jimmy Neutron
look alive [ __ ] I got that V for
Vendetta Vendetta you go for it but I J
for your neck yeah for sucking them
cheek because you know you you don't
want to show that back looking like a
regard no you don't you look more like
Greek salad bit like a Greek sausage you
look like that [ __ ] feta cheese to
you [ __ ]
next point if they're very quick to
admit the wrong now look there's nothing
wrong with an idiot wrong I think it's
very healthy very report what a fun way
will often do which conceit the point to
seem very reasonable seem very
open-minded make you feel good like all
this guy really listens to me and that's
a great way to dislike make women seem
to fed up all he really listens to me
not by telling you what you need to hear
so that you can slide up back in that
big and give you that long letter you
know I do you want to be with someone
less trauma pain something someone is
open mind if I have strong opinion and
someone always came in to everything you
say either they haven't thought of their
opinions very well or secondly they just
really don't care enough about
real disgusted with people they just
give up on every discussion to make you
feel good in a way
drop that person next point hitman and
homies all dresses say yo okay it's like
I don't hang it's like a pack so I got
pack for this one boys ever run solo
they got friends to [ __ ] boy lips okay
because he's a bigot that there is so
with a bird what you doing decide
there's a boy what you doing I did
everything I decide there's a boy what
you doing decide there [ __ ] boy what you
doing decide there's a boy like I don't
know why you my friend never just the
same my life because we're all
individual and we have our own life and
we are old influences end result that's
good why because I take some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] the other individuals will have the
moral core it'll be like you know what
what you think Doug they'll keep me in
check [ __ ] boys don't happen they all
have the same influences it listen to
the same music they listen to the same
[ __ ] as a result the address space and
everywhere you see them in whenever you
see them in pass and you call their name
they turn around my [ __ ] like that boys
man I try to do that - Linda Zoolander
athlete conversely next point if they
lips look wet like they just got done
eating [ __ ] and they always look like
that look at it I can't look at it I
don't want to look at ah god damn me bro
what's up with the music dozens of stuff
this place on the market I understood
why did he gets my like he did some
amazing why you clean your peace go that
nasty
ah man that is the dirtiest [ __ ]
shower every what's a black spot over
there
Marlo the hottie Lexi you just look like
another piece of mo what's his name
hello who's a [ __ ] LL Cool J is twice
I'm Ella who they slide up like you just
call LL Cool J poor boy is the middle
but that song is it's big it's nice and
I'll show how to change
[Music]
[Applause]
boom-boom-boom-boom
go get doing it and doing it laughs next
point uh they claim to be really big
fans of Beyonce you must not know about
me you must not know about me and they
like singing covers of Keyshia Cole the
next one if they never see anything
concrete are always making everything
sound esoteric it unclear
[ __ ] what until you're right they're
like [ __ ] is that how you order a
[ __ ] cheeseburger but I don't know
how I'm feeling about my life right now
I might want to change but you know
maybe today I'll just get the letters
put and you know how the [ __ ] you want
the cheeseburger just say to say just
say it how you want it all cheese how do
you boney how do you need coffee paint
on my back you got five or 60 keys are
you the tides come on something on come
on lil good let's see your father's
business point in this next point they
take a lot of selfies like face up you
in a club
oh yeah this last chapter anybody will
go boom boom
tonight laughs now I'm not worried my
buddy you can probably go well I think
like I've been caught I've been cut won
a club and I look at you like Joe and I
got it stopping and looking like what
you up me like what why if you're mean
you know it clap your hands
got your head did you ain't gonna be
clapping notis tonight that's it for
today's with honestly the best things to
look at when it comes to mug for just
being just honest that's like the real
thing I said male trademarks I think you
can tell when you're dealing with
somebody doesn't seem genuine and who
they are doing babies they don't seem
like they are their own characters they
don't have strong opinions on really big
issues today then to me that's somebody
who doesn't stand for anything and
somebody doesn't stand anything will not
stand behind you why would they stand
behind you when you want to touch they
make sense right you have to have
someone who's involved not necessarily
like on some activist [ __ ] boot care to
some degree and I think you want
somebody ideally cool if I do is genuine
who can be direct when it's necessary so
all this to say avoid the [ __ ] boys if
you can they're out there and you got
like this will probably put out of the
playbook and the [ __ ] yells we're coming
for you next time guys my gosh you like
[ __ ] guys are are over their peers are
over that where you see five guys huh
mama you know what I'm tellin ya what is
it it's pretty alright that's it for
today's video if you guys like that be
sure to LIKE subscribe Facebook YouTube
we don't put everything on Facebook
because YouTube's our main bits follow
us on Instagram all that good stuff
we got a patreon page so if you want
donate a little bit money you know give
us a little thumbs up then we do a
little time that no no we don't
I definitely went the wrong direction
zero but that's it so you know thanks
Howard
a dollar makes me holler hello